[Music]
we can't get enough of the CW hit river
del the casting process was long and
full of surprises you won't believe who
almost played Betty stick around for
number one to find out if this is your
first time here at the things don't
forget to like this video and smash that
subscribe button let's check out the 10
river del casting secrets that surprised
us all Cole Sprouse almost played Archie
Cole Sprouse is a TV sweetheart he won a
ton of fans in his role as Cody in The
Suite Life of Zack and Cody Cody nails
his role as Jughead he really captures
the inquisitive nature of the character
Jughead is cautious observant and
objective Cole does an amazing job
creating all of those characteristics
what if he was never cast in the role so
i self-identify as a loner not a pack
animal when Cole first auditioned he was
asked to read for the role of Archie can
you imagine the show with a different
leading man it's hard for us to even
picture Cole with red hair his portrayal
of Jughead is so spot-on it's like he
was born for the role
luckily the casting team saw that too
it's fortunate that Riverdale nabbed
such a fantastic actor when Cole first
received to the script he wasn't
interested at all he was turned off by
the comics past it wasn't until he took
a closer look that the script caught his
eye
once Cole saw that the comics and the
show had become more dark and mysterious
he decided to give it a shot
we're so glad he did we can't imagine
the show without him they cast Archie
last Archie is arguably the star of
Riverdale the comics the show is based
on are even named after the character he
might be surprised to learn that the
role was the last one cast the casting
process took six months the team was
cautious when filling each role that was
a huge part and why the show is so
perfect the casting director said they
must have seen every redheaded male
actor available for the role
unfortunately none of the ginger actors
really captured the energy they were
looking for the show's version of our
key is upbeat and chipper but also
somewhat sinister that isn't an easy mix
to portray fortunately when New Zealand
native JJ app'
read for the role they realized he was a
perfect fit
next time it could be you your
girlfriend your family it's time to do
something about it
KJ was cast just three days before the
network's tested the cast it couldn't
possibly have been last-minute the
production team was getting nervous
after all they couldn't shoot a pilot if
they didn't have the leading character
we loved KJ is our Chi he's proudly half
Samoan his natural hair is a gorgeous
deep brown we think he looks great as a
redhead too
he pulls off both the do and the role
perfectly several cast members were
rejected at first
Betty Cooper is a major character on
Riverdale she's central to the story and
we can't imagine anyone but Lily
Reinhart playing her Lilly was
interviewed by coke tour and opened up
about the casting process she said it
was a nationwide casting call that took
many months she wanted the world to know
that the role didn't just fall into her
lap she worked really hard to get it
Lily revealed that at first she was
turned down for the role as Betty if
that wasn't shocking enough so what's
Camilla Mendes who plays Veronica and
the leading man KJ atha what can you
imagine the show with a different
leading cast the roles of Betty Veronica
and Archie are the heart of Riverdale we
can't imagine all three of these roles
cast differently thankfully the actors
auditioning for those parts worked
incredibly hard they showed the
production staff that they had what it
takes
casting a TV show is a complicated
process the talent chosen can make or
break the show sometimes roles are cast
recast are even rewritten in the process
it's not unusual for an actor to be
turned down for a part only to get a
call to come read for it again we're
just glad that these three actors got
the call and made it onto the show Casey
taught auditions for Archie Casey cought
plays would have been most developed and
deep characters on the show we can't
imagine anyone else in the role of Kevin
Keller he brings a perfect blend of sass
energy and depth to the character it
seems like a natural fit but it actually
took some work to place Casey on the
cast when he first auditioned he
actually read for the part of Archie
we have no doubt that this talented
actor could totally nail the leading
role on the show
Archie wasn't the perfect fit for him he
auditioned for another role before he
ever read for Kevin Casey also
auditioned for the role of Jackie
as talented as Casey is that wasn't
quite perfect either
when he finally read for Kevin the
production team knew they had hit the
mark
Casey is terrific in the role as the
sheriff's gay son the actor says he has
a lot in common with his character they
both have first and last names that
start with the same letter
Casey says he and Kevin both strive to
spread joy wherever they go we're so
glad Casey finally found the perfect
Riverdale role the show just wouldn't be
the same without him why the hell not
Madeleine posh thought she was
auditioning for another role
Madeleine posh seems like she was born
to play Sheryl blossom the actress isn't
at all like the mean girl she portrays
but she fits the role so well it's hard
to imagine her played by anyone else
during the casting process madeleine
wasn't considered for Cheryl at first
the casting crew had her read for Betty
it's hard to imagine an actor who was so
good at playing a bad girl as Betty
Madeleine is super talented so we're
sure she could have done it after months
of waiting to hear back about her role
she finally got a call
it wasn't the call she expected the
producers asks her to come in and read
for Cheryl and the chemistry was
immediate it was obvious that she was
born to play the role her red hair fits
the characters spicy personality on
screen her chemistry with Betty is
perfect - she's an essential part of the
cast and we can't imagine her and any
other role we're so glad she impressed
the producers with her auditions for
Betty
if they hadn't called her back to read
for Cheryl we might not have the perfect
scream zing
Olivia Ryan Stern read for Veronica
Veronica is one of the main characters
on Riverdale reading for her would be a
dream come true for any actress that
dream came true for 24 year-old Olivia
Ryan Stern she was called in for five or
six auditions only to learn that she
wouldn't be cast as the role she had
done such a great job auditioning for
Veronica but the production staff called
her back to read for another part Olivia
came back to read for the part of Tina
Patel Tina isn't one of the original
comic book characters she was written
just for the show Tina is one of the
queen bees Olivia says her character is
not a nice girl nice girl or not
we love Tina and we're glad olivia was
cast she worked hard for her role on the
show and she's doing a great job
we don't doubt she'd be an awesome
Veronica but Tina was practically
written for her Olivia said she tried to
give an air of mystery to the character
during her audition before landing the
role on River del Olivia played parts on
supernatural and psych
she's even appeared in music videos for
the band's Mary Ann's Trench she's
clearly got a wide range of talents we
see a great future ahead for her Charlie
de PUE auditioned for Archie Riverdale
has aired two seasons and is working on
a third that's a lot of episodes to
spend bonding with the characters and
the actors playing them this late in the
game it's hard to imagine anyone else in
the roles we've come to love Charlie de
PUE recently took to Instagram to talk
about his Riverdale audition and the
role he would eventually lands on
another show
Charlie posted to fans that he had
auditioned hard for a role and lost it
he was then called in to read for the
part of Archie on Riverdale the actor
said he was being heavily considered for
the role but then it fell through
Charlie actually considered quitting
acting all together he's been building a
career for eight years and just wasn't
where he wanted to be finally the show
he auditioned for before Riverdale
called him back he had landed the role
of Jake salt on famous and loved he may
not have made it into the cast of
Riverdale but he did land a significant
role on a successful show Charlie said
he's so glad he didn't quit acting while
he was frustrated he would have never
landed such a great part
Charlie proves that hard work and
dedication pay off Kasey caught tried
for Jughead it's hard to imagine two
characters more different than Kevin
Keller and Jughead
Kevin is bright and clever he tries to
make people happy everywhere he goes jag
had is more reserved in observance he
decides to take a more objective
approach as different as these
characters are it's hard to imagine but
the same actor auditioned for both after
he auditioned for Archie Casey caught
bread for Jughead we're glad Casey found
his calling as Kevin Keller it steams
he's glad he took this role too he took
to Twitter to tell his fans that he
dodged for both Archie and Jughead
he says he'll stick to Kevin Casey's
personality is
perfect for the role we've tried to
imagine him as the brooding and
calculating Jughead but we can't he must
have really impressed the producers if
he auditions for two roles and kept
getting called back again and again it's
not unusual for an actor to audition for
a role and be called back to read for
another part actors may not be a perfect
fits for a character but their talents
may still get the attention of the
casting crew in Casey's own words
everything worked out exactly the way it
was supposed to cool right yeah you know
I think I'm gonna pass it's all a little
too big luck major curta wasn't the
first actor to play Dilton doily
Dilton doily is a beloved reoccurring
character their brilliant boy scout adds
depth to the show observant fans will
notice that Dilton underwent some
changes between the pilot and the first
episode of season 1 during the casting
process rumors circulated that both
Daniel yang and major kurta were being
considered for the role the show
initially cast Dana yang he took to
Twitter to tell his friends that the
show had been picked up he said he was
happy to play the role of Dilton he
played the character in the pilot
episode no one knows why the change
happened no official statement has been
made and the actors haven't discussed it
publicly all we know is that major curta
portrayed the character from then on
both actors are great at their job we
can't help but wonder why the show
decided to make the switch major plays
the part perfectly the characters quirky
and unique it takes our really talented
actor to play such a complex role we're
sure Daniel would have continued to do a
great job but we loved nature as the
most famous voice Scout in town
Catherine Langford auditions for Betty
if you're a fan of Riverdale you can't
help but love Betty the blonde beauty is
a major character on the show it's hard
to imagine anyone else playing Betty
Cooper Lily has won five Teen Choice
Awards in her role on the show so far
but what if an iconic brunette actress
has been cast instead before Lily was
cast Catherine Langford auditions for
the role the award-winning actress would
have delivered an awesome performance
but the character would be very
different
the casting worked out perfectly not
only is really perfect for her role as
Betty but Catherine went on to be cast
in 13 reasons why Panabaker is an iconic
character she wouldn't be the same if
another actor played her there
Jeane reasons why was a huge hit
Katherine went on to be nominated for a
Golden Globe for her role the show would
be nominated for enemy
we're glad Katherine held out 13 reasons
why she would have been a fantastic
Betty Cooper but who would have played
Hannah Baker Katherine had a great time
auditioning for the show she even went
out for a falafel with Camila Mendez and
another after auditioning for the role
she may not have gotten the part but she
did make some new friends
we hope you loved these Riverdale
casting secrets catch you later
[Music]